photos of a smiling and relieved
nazininzagari ratcliffe last month
after her five-year-old deal seemed
nearly over having spent four years in
jail she'd spent the final months of her
prison sentence under house arrest
at her parents home in tehran wearing an
ankle tag to monitor her movements
but hopes she might soon return to the
uk were dashed by a new charge of making
propaganda
and now a guilty verdict which nazinen's
husband emphatically rejects
last time round we got dragged into
court this time around we've got a
sentence
um so you know we've watched this
now for five years where we're clearly
being held
as collateral in something else um and
we are still
part of something else a project manager
with the charity the thompson reuters
foundation
was arrested at tehran airport in april
2016 after visiting her parents
she was later convicted on a national
security charge an allegation she has
always denied
the new propaganda allegation dates back
even
further this new conviction relates to
an event here
at the iranian embassy in london back in
2009 a full
12 years ago an anti-government protest
attended by
nazanin zigari radcliffe at which she
gave an interview to the bbc
persian service nazanin's friends and
supporters are frankly astounded and
appalled
that it should be resurrected now for
the purposes of this
new criminal case in tehran and they
fear that there are bigger forces at
work here
is one of a number of dual nationals in
iranian detention
many observers draw a direct link to a
550 million dollar debt owed by britain
to iran
for a consignment of chieftain tanks
ordered before
iran's islamic revolution which the uk
never delivered
there's also the issue of broader
sanctions and iran's nuclear ambitions
i don't think it's right at all that
nazine should be
uh sentenced to any more time in in jail
i think that it was wrong i think it's
wrong that she's there
in the in the first place and we'll be
working
very hard to secure her release from
iran her ability to return to her family
here in the uk
just as we work for all our dual
national cases in iran nazarene's legal
team have 21 days to appeal against her
new conviction
and they've already said that they will
paul brennan al jazeera
london